ever slept around because I don't agree
with it
in men men love me because I've got a
nice personality because I'm a majority
a majority girls
I'm fun you know so the guy I'm with now
he he's so so kind and loving and he
lives in Kent and he's lovely you know
so
yeah but it took us a long time to get
over losing my partner
a long time I'm sorry to hear that sorry
just to ask um so obviously you haven't
you know you haven't slept around and
obviously you've done a long time
relationship rip to your partner would
you recommend do you know women that
slept around have they got the same
results that have you had would you
recommend it do you consider sleeping
around having a high body account or
something that a woman should as a badge
of honor
I know a few girls that do escorting and
like
work in the industry in the colony
I don't know if you didn't hear the
rules excuse me excuse me lady in the
red the like there's um code words for
certain words because they're not
monetized sorry sorry yeah
so it's porn we don't say any offensive
words yeah no problems so the con they
can't find a relationship because men
don't want to be with a girl like that
and why is that what do the men say
because they've been running I was very
embarrassed of what the friends will see
other family if they find out like
dating a girl like that during run out
yeah so um so in back to what I was
saying about what why men don't want a
woman that's with a high body count so
you've actually seen that in like in
your life and you could speak to other
like young girls about who think men
don't mind yeah that's all
so
basically
basically men don't want women with high
bloody counts straight up yeah I don't
care what no woman says I don't care any
of your reasoning I don't care what your
excuses are or it's the mental I don't
care it's your fault you opened your
legs bro at the end of the day a guy
doesn't want a woman that slept with a
football team basketball team lacrosse
team swim team rap team street team
flyer team we don't want that well we
like we like our box to be exclusive to
us now obviously in an idea in a
realistic mindset we know that more than
likely the woman that you're gonna meet
especially if you're over the age of
like what 17. it's probably it's
probably slept with somebody at some
point so it's not like guys are looking
for Perfection we're just not looking
for the town football but that's what it
is real talk and I don't see why there's
so much pushback because I think again
as I said earlier women you not know
that it's not a good thing that's why
more time you lie about it RAV that I
don't understand the argument though
yeah we know that like
no no there was a slide
we do know that men don't want women to
have slept with a lot of people it's
been like that since the end of time so
where do we go from here
yeah
we know that you say that but now
currently especially what's going on now
there seems to be a pushback with why
women don't seem to understand why they
wasn't told by their by their brother by
their dad by their mom why so that so
when people say that just says to me you
I've never had parents that loved you or
you never had a brother or to let you
know because I've got three sisters and
one of the one of the most important
things I would have taught them um
especially my younger sister was about
being respectful she's married we've
tried all of my sisters are married with
child if you don't know going out and
open up your legs to random men because
they took you out for some food or for a
little trip is is devaluing yourself
then you was not taught right and this
is why you're gonna end up racking up
your body count when you finally meet a
guy that likes you tell him your body
can't see what happens that's all I'm
saying now another thing another thing
in this as well is that
um the fact that a lot of us grew up
without fathers and in the home that is
a very key factor in there because for
instance yeah let's not even talk about
the women the guys yeah us guys and I'm
a product of a single parent home yeah a
lot of us guys we measure our manhood by
the number of women we sleep with yeah
so let's say for instance
um okay I live with my mum I've got a
sister and she looks to me as a role
model right but she sees that I sleep
around with loads of guilts do you get
what I'm saying that's already a bad
influence then she doesn't have a dad
that can show her unconditional love and
doesn't expect anything sexual back she
goes out into the world with the only
references her brother sleeps around and
she's now got Daddy Issues looking for a
dad out there in the world and she
sleeps with one Tyrone two Tyrone three
Tyrone five ten now she's better now
she's Twisted now or woman ain't [ __ ]
and all men are dogs and blah blah blah
bro is is a big [ __ ] at the end
of the day you get what I'm saying so
it's a sad it's a sad reality but it is
the reality like I'm saying and I think
that
um a lot of the media has a part to play
in it as well because say a lot of
chicks these days are Disciples of cardi
B making a stallion look at the media
look at the way Society is run Amber
what is it Amber Amber Rose that was
that not that long ago bro how can there
be a [ __ ] water parade saying that um
it's a good thing you're crazy oh let me
finish what I'm saying RAV yeah how can
that be a normal thing that women could
come out and say oh yeah yeah just sleep
around yeah fruit bro that's mad and
there was no pushback from good women
where's the pushback for that bro like
come on bro we had whap and we got uh I
don't know Megan and stallion come out
with something recently some mad videos
city girls saying uh [ __ ] [ __ ] get
some money all of this bro like this is
this is stripper culture and I think
that a lot of times women are very
highly influenced but what they see on
the screen especially if they don't have
a functional family in their home so
they look in the screen oh this is cool
this is trending I'm gonna copy that
that's the role model
um for me as a young woman and it
usually starts when they're young and
impressionable and it just Carries On
um I hate everything you're saying but
can I also ask you a question
what makes what do you feel makes you as
an individual a good man what do you
bring to the table I never said that was
a good man though
but everything you're expecting from a
woman
what do you bring to her well first
first of all I'm not I'm before no no
before you answer them no before you
answer the question I ain't coming for
you yeah I know so don't I'm not coming
for you either
I'm just nice it's good but I'm just
cool what do you think makes you okay
I'll just say I'll say um in terms of
that if I was in a situation where I
wanted to be the good guy I'm not saying
I'm necessarily I'm some may say I'm
sorry otherwise yeah but what I'm saying
is fundamentally protection and
provision and I said this in another
podcast here where protection is very
undervalued broth because at the end of
the day we live in a very scary evil
world where a lot of bad things happen
very consistently and at the end of the
day if we compare me and you you're more
vulnerable than I am brav at the end of
the day you walking around at 3am and me
walking around at 3am is two different
worlds do you know what I'm saying so
you being with me you've already got a
benefit straight off the bat well
protections
a pardon no so if I'm with you like I'll
be protected of course you would be well
I would be the first 999 before you dial
999. I lie
and then obviously
um with the provision I don't expect you
to pay for nothing for me obviously
there's some bums out there there's some
wastement out there that they need a
good they need a place to stay well I
don't need nothing from you brev
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible